and in yet another terrifying example of
the Border being completely out of
control a band of suspected Smugglers
are still on the loose in Texas after a
high-speed car chase and firing gunshots
at Texas officers Texas DPS warning on
Christmas Eve quote the suspect remains
at large and all occupants are
considered armed and dangerous Jonathan
Fahey is a former ice director and
former DHS Deputy assistant secretary
and joins us now Jonathan good morning
to you we wanted to ask you about this
situation because it escalated in a
really serious way and like Ashley just
said now DPS is saying suspects are
still on the loose and they're
considered armed and dangerous what's
your response
yeah it really is amazing and and your
your title is great just this border
disorder because we have no control
whatsoever of our Southern border and it
doesn't seem like this Administration is
going to do anything about it and these
are Texas DPS officials having to deal
with stuff the federal government should
be dealing with but it's so derelict in
their Duty and you know starting I guess
tomorrow with title of 42 going away
there's really going to be no control
whatsoever the border and people are
going to be in so much danger because of
this Administration unwilling to enforce
the law
right and when you think about this
Omnibus spending package this 1.7 uh
dollar spending package one of the
things it has is aiding illegal migrants
pilot programs that's 20 million dollars
that could be going to places like
securing our border so why are we not
using those funds to instead hire more
border patrol or doing something to
prevent things like the situation that I
just read about from happening
yeah it is really interesting you talked
about the Omnibus Bill and it's like it
does show that when Congress wants to
deal with an issue like Ukraine or
something else they can all come
together and put money on the table and
deal with it but neither Congress or
this Administration has any interest
whatsoever in dealing with the situation
the southern border or improving it
there really is just such a commitment
to open borders and it is unwavering and
we're going to see mass chaos we're
going to see overdose deaths increase
human trafficking increase and there is
nothing going to be done to stop this
and it's really it's so beyond
disappointing that the American people
are really left out of this you know of
the budget or anything else no one cares
about what affects the American people
the most because this certainly affects
American people probably more than
almost any other issue and there's no
concern and no efforts to address it so
the Biden Administration requested title
42 stay in place until the 27th which is
tomorrow the Supreme Court court has yet
to rule on what they're going to do
which I think is the hold up what do you
what kind of timeline do you think that
we're working with as to when title 42
will actually uh go away and then what
happens next
yeah I really don't know what what as
far as the timeline is but you know
what's an interesting irony about this
last week the White House Press
Secretary was was suggesting that the
White House was sort of a bystander at
the mercy of the Court ahead no no
opinion on this issue or actually
implied that they wanted title 42 to
stay and then later I believe that day
or the next day they filed this brief
saying no tunnel 42 should end and end
on the 27th but you know I I don't know
what the Supreme Court will do but I do
know what will happen that things will
get even worse at the border this
Administration will do nothing other
than simply they view the role of the
border patrol at this stage is simply to
process migrants remember they were in
front of the Supreme Court like uh
earlier I believe in earlier in December
fighting to keep aggravated felon
illegal aliens in the country so this
Administration wants nothing other than
a purely open border and border patrol
is simply to process migrants into the
country and they've made it very clear
that once you're here you're never
getting kicked out and you'll be treated
as well or better than American citizens
right and excuse me we've heard from
fronting up with a plan once title 42
ends which we don't know exactly when
it's going to happen but they say
they've got a plan and then that new
book came out uh last week and they were
talking about how the president is so
mad and angry and cursing in the West
Wing so do you think they have a
actually a plan in place that they're
just gonna surprise us with here at the
last minute or do you think this is just
going to be the Wild Wild West and
continue to be
horrible down there at the southern
border
yeah it doesn't seem like there is any
plan whatsoever and again I don't think
they really care I mean they they
probably prefer bad things not to happen
but their highest priority is this open
border and they will do nothing other
than to to encourage as much illegal
immigration as possible and you see all
these bad things happening and they're
just they're just hopeful that the uh
the media will largely ignore it and the
Border will remain open and massive
illegal immigration will continue and
that's all they want and all they care
about and anytime they're given a choice
between Public Safety and the open
border they always choose the open
border they they never put the interests
of the American people first they never
put their safety first their health
first their Education First they always
put the interest of illegal aliens in
the Democratic party first and foremost
and it really is disgraceful because
they have a responsibility to protect
the public and they have been so
derelict in this responsibility well
Jonathan the news certainly is
continuing when it comes to these
Twitter files as well part nine was
released on Christmas Eve and it
revealed how government agencies not
just the FBI multiple are actually tied
to the social media Network journalist
Matt tahibi posted this tweet saying the
files show the FBI acting as a doorman
to a vast program of social media
surveillance and censorship encompassing
agencies across the federal government
from the state department to the
Pentagon to the CIA so what do you think
the nature of these relationships were
between these government agencies and
Twitter
yeah that that's really you know another
thing you know sort of a part of the
same issue is you see this
Administration or you see you see the
government working to you know censor
opposing views or what they call
disinformation and it really is ironic
when when you see what the government
what the information they put out is
that they call correct information when
you when you think of the Border or
think of other issues they don't put out
accurate information so even if this was
somehow a worthwhile goal they certainly
you know they certainly shouldn't be the
ones in charge of it because they don't
put out accurate information themselves
and some of the some of the things that
they've censored you know have it's been
laughable in terms of people joking
about the don't forget to vote on
Wednesday and things like that but it
really does show how pervasive this is
and you wonder this is just Twitter so
what else is going on and and the other
thing is where's the media on this the
media seems so
just I guess agreeable to this notion of
censorship because they seem to think as
long as it's the stuff they agree with
they're fine with it but it really
should disturb Americans that the United
States government is is censoring
information that they're allowed to hear
and you know to suggest that they're
doing it for altruistic reasons when we
know like we just talked about that
Public Safety border issues crime issues
they always put politics first so to
suggest that they put Public Safety
First here ahead of politics I think
that's that's really hard to believe you
know James Comer has said uh that part
of these investigations will be with
Twitter it'll be it could it could
extend to Facebook wherever it needs to
go with these social media platforms but
when they bring them in to investigate
them and ask them questions do you think
that places these organizations like the
FBI and the CIA do you think they're
just so untouchable that anything that
things are just not going to happen to
them or do you think they're going to be
held accountable for basically what has
just been put out for us to see in plain
sight
yeah I'm sorry I didn't hear all of your
question but but I do you do with the
censorship issue with Twitter it is what
you know when you have these multiple
agencies working together what what you
know what else could they be doing with
their time that is in the greater
interest of the American public is there
really anything about this that is
serving the American public and that
that should be the the what the one of
the questions the second question is is
this legal and
is it a good thing that the government
is involved in the information people
get and I think most people would agree
that the answer is no and to see how
again how pervasive this is it really
should scare people because this is all
this is what we know about and you know
it's on these issues now but it could be
on other issues and they'll you know
they call things misinformation or
whatever and you see the Democratic
party doing this anything they disagree
with these days they they can categorize
it as misinformation and try to shut it
down or try to bully people try to
intimidate them from expressing their
views and it really should scare most
Americans because most Americans
Americans deserve to have their voices
heard and they also deserve to have the
right to listen to
whatever they whatever they want to
listen to not just what the government
deems important for them to listen to
Jonathan Fahey thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it